haben sie diese woche auch so derbe
gefeiert tag der deutschen einheit oder
wie ich ihn liebevoll nennen unseren
spenden stay ja ja 28 jahre
wiedervereinigung gewürdigt mit einem
großen festakt in berlin war geil oder
ein mega event vor allem der show teil
seien sie dabei wenn am dritten oktober
bundesratspräsident michael müller sein
amt an daniel hinter den
ministerpräsidenten von schleswig
holstein über gibt seien sie dabei wenn
daniel dingsbums einen anderen farblosen
brillenträger ersetzt
da werden sie noch ihren enkeln nicht
von erzählt aber mal ganz ernsthaft ich
habe es mir angeguckt es war wieder mal
ein sehr schöner festakt wirklich und da
gibt es ja diese wunderbare tradition
ich weiß gar nicht ob sie die canon bei
genau diesem termin lässt unsere
kanzlerin gern mal die seele baumeln
also kurz gesagt sie rast weg hier zum
beispiel 2012 bei der rede von lammert
ein vereintes demokratisches deutschland
dann letztes jahr beim steine hier
und mittwoch natürlich bei herrn
schäuble guck mal ja ja gut meine der
schlaf vor mitternacht ist so wichtig
das ist einfach so das ist erwiesen
dabei hat der schäuble nur gute rede
gehalten und uns alle zu mehr
gelassenheit gemahnt diesen historischen
zeiten rechter völlig recht auch im
prozess der einheit gibt es eindeutig
fortschritte erfolgsgeschichten da auf
der minusseite stellen wir fest immer
noch kein dax-unternehmen in den neuen
bundesländern und fast alle
schlüsselpositionen in politik
verwaltung und medien werden weiter mit
wessis besetzt nur und hört man auf zu
meckern da drüben was ihr ossis allein
im letzten jahr gekriegt habt ein
starkes signal war ganz am anfang der
dies der in unserer jetzigen
bundesregierung die ansiedlung des
bundesfernstraßen amtes in leipzig oder
etwa auch die vergabe des
kompetenzzentrums kompetenzzentrums alt
nach mecklenburg vorpommern
sie liest ihr habt doch das
kompetenzzentrum wald wenn ihr brach
seit kriegt brandenburg noch das
kompetenzzentrum spreewaldgurke aber
dann ist auch mal gut wirklich laut
einheits bericht hole der osten in fast
allen bereichen wirklich auf ist droht
langfristig sagen die forscher nur eine
gefahr
bevölkerungsschwund zu viele menschen
gehen weg aus dem osten ist fakt vor
allem frauen wandern ab das ist ein
problem auf die dauern
ja qualifizierte wandern ab und die
meisten zuwanderer wollen auch nicht
mehr die neuen länder
komisch weil die klar im westen gibt es
auch leute die glauben heimatgefühle und
wut auf flüchtlinge bringen jobs zurück
aber im osten treten die halt sehr
dominant auf muss man trotzdem im
gespräch bleiben
es tut not dass man diesen dialog mit
den bürgern sucht das gehört zur
wahrheit dazu nicht jeder traut sich in
eine solche robuste art der
auseinandersetzung häufig eine sehr
robuste sprache die auch anders ist als
im westen
das muss man aushalten
muss man aushalten
diesen dialog muss man aushalten jetzt
nicht im heute-show fanshop unser neues
subtiles protest t shirt wir sind die
arbeiterklasse du dämliche schweiz
ja das ist mein körper fakt ist aber
auch jeder dritte ostdeutsche ist
niedriglöhner oder aufstocker das macht
es für die afd leider zu leicht zu
ernten und gerade in der nachwendezeit
haben sich verletzungen und demütigungen
aufgestaut deswegen fordert der
sächsische spd politiker martin dulig
jetzt eine gesamtdeutsche wahrheits und
versöhnungskommission in der das alles
nochmal schonungslos auf den tisch kommt
der sich ossis und wessis einfach mal
sagen sollen was sie nervt eine tolle
idee
herzlich willkommen zu jetzt wird es
schmutzig die schonungslose ossi wessi
bereits kommission mit olaf schubert
ja ich begrüße alle recht herzlich hier
bei der wahrheitskommission 28 jahre
kränkung und demütigung wir arbeiten das
jetzt hier im akut unter männern auf
würde ich sagen und dann wird aber
wirklich auch mal ein schlussstrich
gezogen werden ich meine in südafrika
hat die wahrheitskommission ja auch sehr
gut funktioniert also vermitteln
zwischen den schwarzen und weißen und
ich spreche jetzt hier für die
ostdeutschen [ __ ] und ich meine es ist
ja gar nicht so schlimm ich würde meine
ich hatte ja nichts gegen den
westdeutschen man muss ja auch dass wir
sind ja keine richtigen männer sich alle
ist er so verweichlicht der allergiker
mit burn out also ja ich meine gab es
bei uns ja meistens auch nicht burnout
je so halbschuhe des grafenauer ich hab
noch stahl geschmiedet wirklich mit der
bloßen faust
und damit der stirn und hier in köln
hier höre ich immer ja wir sind harte
jungs wir haben hart gefeiert ich meine
bloß weise mal die zweite flasche wodka
getrunken haben
das machte sie nebenbei hinter
frühschicht so und ein wirklich großes
grundlegendes problem ist die im osten
fühlen uns nicht genug gesehen und das
ist natürlich eine umstellung nicht denn
damals wurde ja alles beobachtet aber
wenn man den ostlern doch zufällig
irgendwie mal wahrnimmt dann kommt immer
das gleiche öl schreckliche klamotten
furchtbare frisuren also bitte ist der
absolut fit ich ja ständig wird man
immer januar jammer ist ich meine ich ja
überhaupt nicht rum keiner jammert im
osten herum entschuldige wir haben meine
erfahrung gibt es aber schon wieder
unterbrochen
und wenn der sagt immer du hast sollte
sei dürfe bei uns in der schule dagegen
die zensoren nur bis fünf bis sechs wenn
die fünf für eure doofheit nicht mehr
ausgereicht hat und das zeigt sich ja
heute noch hier stichworte hat mir
gerade diesen abgang skandal ihre
manipuliert autos und seite auch noch so
blöde euch dabei erwischen zu lassen
ich meine wenn man betrügt da muss man
auch mal durchziehen wie wie bei uns im
osten doping hat die kugelstoßerin die
hatten volkswirte hatten sogar noch
einen schnauzbart am steiß
ja und ich meine
das wird doping gab es doch so weißt du
was mich nervt können wir auch mal zu
kommen was mich nervt ist dass wir im
westen so unfassbar viele sachen von
euch jetzt übernehmen mussten seit der
wende zum beispiel hier den blöden
grünen abbiege files zum kotzen oder
jetzt mal ehrlich vor dem mauerfall war
bei uns also im richtigen deutschland er
war ganz klar ampel rot ich bleib stehen
feierabend und jetzt weiß ich gar nicht
mehr
irgendwann muss abbiegen soll aber
gucken ja wie denn jetzt das ist für
mich kommunismus ganz ehrlich ach ja und
wolfgang lippert war scheiße in wetten
dass vielen dank herr lippi hat der hat
das richtig gut gemacht die hat ganz
menschlich motor ist
und wenn der russe bisher schneller
gewesen wäre da kommt nichts muss hätte
im westen hier genauso gut funktioniert
also schlecht apropos funktionieren
sagte er immer die ost frauen sind
besser im bett
ich meine wer sagt nur die frauen zu
sechs gehören immer zwei
also bis so und jetzt immer mehr frauen
wandern ab in den westen und wer bleibt
zurück der mann unter wulff
aber ich muss sagen ich bleibe gerne
drüben was soll ich hier in nrw alles
abgegrenzt und marode
bei uns dagegen alles neue schicke
städte moderne straßen denn hier drüben
die haben nämlich wirklich mal geld in
die hand genommen
und wir haben uns aufgebaut und da muss
ich mich fragen was habt ihr hier
gemacht
ja dann müsst ihr mal hand anlegen
wir wollen natürlich dass es euch
genauso gut geht und deshalb bin ich
doch helfen denn ihr fragen habt oder du
ruft an selbst mitten am tag
ich meine wir wollen ja auch die
nächsten 28 jahre irgendwie gemeinsam
friedlich über die zeit kriegen
schaut man dass oliver komm her wir sind
wir alle arbeiterklasse hätte dem
distrikt 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]